the movie is set in Mexico and it opens
up with a montage of green elements like
a lady painted in green green water
flowing down the stairs and the streets
covered in strange green liquid at this
time Mexico is going through an intense
civil unrest where thousands of people
are perishing each day in the next scene
we see a hospital where the staff is
rushing to clear all the beds for the
seriously injured demonstrators at the
same Hospital an elderly man named
Rolando is accompanying his wife Alicia
she is so ill that she requires an
expensive surgery to replace a heart
valve however the hospital is unwilling
to take the risk at this time the doctor
advises Rolanda to seek out another
Private Hospital for his wife saying
their beds are currently overwhelmed
this is a huge problem for the middle
class Orlando as the surgery will cost
him around a hundred thousand pesos
which is a substantial sum of money
outside the hospital the city is going
through a deadly turmoil guns are being
fired incessantly helicopters are
whizzing dangerously low over the city
explosions are taking place here and
there and people are being killed as if
their lives hold no importance in order
to combat the situation the state
apparatus has deployed military forces
however instead of maintaining peace
more bullets are fired and hence the
death toll continues to rise amidst all
the chaos in the city we are introduced
to Ivan a high-ranking government
official he is currently hosting a
lavish post-wetting party at his opulent
Mansion for his beloved daughter
Marianne while dressed affluent
individuals and business magnates attend
the celebration presenting lavish gifts
and cash to the newlyweds Marianne hands
over these gifts to her mother who
stores them safely in a vault shortly
after Marianne's mother becomes anxious
as the water in the area turns green
indicating the onset of a rebellion
concerned she summons her husband but
the green color surprisingly vanishes
before he arrives Ivan then returns to
the party after telling her not to worry
however his wife remains uneasy and
instructs the head waitress Marta to
search for the source of the green you
Dr Seuss is hanging out around here
somewhere after a while a prominent
government official named Victor arrives
at the party prompting Ivan to escort
his family outside to greet him Victor
informs the family that their land
permit has been approved this indicates
that despite the precarious situation in
the city the rich have been getting away
with all their lavish needs not long
after Victor becomes aware of the
growing danger so he and his family
hastily depart from there in the midst
of the ongoing wedding celebration
Rolando makes his presence it turns out
he is the family's Gardener he
approaches Marianne's mother humbly and
begs for 200 000 pesos for his wife's
emergency surgery the woman returns to
the party and asks Ivan and her son
Daniel for some cash she gathers around
000 pesos and hands them over to Orlando
however the money is insufficient
moments later he meets Marianne and
informs her of his predicament being the
kind woman that she is Marianne
immediately decides to help him so oh
she summons Daniel however he simply
hands him some more money and asks him
to leave Marianne is disappointed by
this response and tries to access the
safe to retrieve additional funds for
Orlando but discovers that the password
has been changed she then approaches her
family members but no one is willing to
assist causing her to become angry left
with no other option she brings her own
credit card but by this time Rolando has
already left as a solution she takes her
father's driver Christian and leaves the
wedding party in secret to visit
Rolando's residence a few moments later
they learned that the police have
blocked the roads around her mansion in
anticipation of the impending attacks as
a result of this they are forced to take
a longer route while driving they listen
to the radio and learn that protests
have taken over the streets but the
authorities have yet to respond back at
the Mansion the family eventually gets
to know that the bride has gone missing
causing them to panic as they contact
the authorities the head waitress Marta
calls her son Christian and gets to know
that Marianne is with him she asks her
to immediately return to the mansion but
Marianne claims that the guests can wait
Elisha cannot after a while the two
somehow managed to make their way to
Rolando's house Christine turns out to
be the old man's nephew upon entering
the house he tries to contact the
authorities but the phone lines are not
working despite the difficult
circumstances Marianne promises that she
will take Alicia to the hospital on the
other hand the protesters who are
dressed in red and green uh-oh break
into the Mansion their leader shoots
Ivan causing full-blown panic
surprisingly instead of protecting his
employer the security Chief shoots the
guests and assists the protesters in
ransacking the house he also takes
Marian's mother hostage and forces her
to open the safe once she does he
finishes her off cold-heartedly
meanwhile the workers ransacked the
Mansion stealing all of its belongings
and valuables the only one who stays
loyal to her owners is Marta she hides
in a closet and discreetly calls her son
to warn him not to return unfortunately
one of the protesters spots her and
knocks her down the demonstrators then
destroy whatever is left in the house
and in the process even Daniel's
pregnant wife is killed it appears that
the wealthier facing retribution for
their greed and conceit the color green
is a real [__] later that night martyr
regains Consciousness and discovers that
the Mansion has been completely
destroyed she hurries back home while
the chaos continues the following
morning Ivan is loaded into an ambulance
and taken to the hospital now the
situation at the Mansion finally appears
to be under control elsewhere Marianne
decides to return home so Christian
steps outside to check on the situation
during this time he is suddenly
confronted by several military soldiers
who offer to accompany Marianne home
they trust the soldiers and Marianne
boards their truck unfortunately the
soldiers turn out to be rude and demand
that Marianne give up her phone Jewelry
and Watch we see that the city is
devolved into shambles with dead bodies
strewn about instead of returning
Marianne home the soldiers transport her
to a military base and place her in a
cell with other victims the occupants
seem to be mostly relatives of affluent
individuals and influential politicians
inside the facility they are each
ordered to write down their personal
information and contacts which will
later be used for blackmail at midnight
the women are awakened and coerced into
satisfying The Soldier's desires on the
contrary Daniel is overwhelmed when
asked to handle the administrative tasks
for his wife and mother's funeral later
he approaches The prominent government
official Victor and asks for his
assistance in finding Marianne Victor
promptly agrees and he introduces them
to General Oribe who will assist them in
the same in the next scene the family
Mourns at the funeral of their deceased
loved ones the same day Ivan is
discharged from the hospital but he
still has to follow his Medical
Treatments at home a short time later
Victor pays him a visit and assures him
that they will find his daughter as soon
as possible in the midst of all this the
rich people's Reign and power begin to
crumble as their servants are no longer
subservient to their employers make your
own damn salads back at the military
base the soul soldiers record videos of
the victims being beaten up and send
them to their families demanding a large
ransom for their release at this point
the military appears to have complete
control over the citizens who are forced
to comply with their demands a
nationwide curfew has been imposed and
those who disobey are shot to death
elsewhere Orlando becomes really
concerned about his wife's deteriorating
health so he steps outside to ask the
soldiers for permission to cross the
border despite their initial warning
Rolando persists in his request due to
which he is shot and killed on the spot
not long after Alicia also dies because
of her illness and lack of Medical Care
Christian Marta and other mourners
gather at the church to offer their
condolences meanwhile at the Mansion
Daniel receives a phone call from the
military base demanding a ransom of 1
million dollars in exchange for
Marianne's release frightened by the
threat he and his dad go to Victor's
office and show him the video footage to
seek assistance upon hearing about
Marianne's abduction General Oribe
promises to use is all available
information to track down the kidnappers
in the next scene some of the kidnappers
you took Marianne realized that their
leader plans to pay them only 200 000
pesos which they believe is insufficient
as a result they decide to make their
fortune in another way they pay a secret
visit to Christian's house and implore
him to collect eight hundred thousand
pesos in exchange for Marianne's safe
return in order to show their Authority
and power they provide Marta and
Christian with two travel passes the
next day the mother-son Duo uses the
travel passes and heads to their
employer's Mansion to deliver the
unsettling news desperate and left with
no other choice Ivan agrees to pay 800
000 pesos and Daniel hands over the
money to them in the hope of getting
Marianne back Christine and Marta then
return home with the money and hand it
over to the kidnappers unfortunately the
greedy kidnappers demand another 1
million pesos claiming that the initial
payment was only a down payment we
really like green do you get it yet at
the military base hostage number three
is is released after his family pays the
ransom however as soon as he gets out of
the cell he is heartlessly shot to death
the remaining hostages are shaken by the
sound of gunfire and scream in shock it
indicates that the military is not only
demanding Ransom money but also taking
the lives of the hostages making it
unlikely for any of them to be reunited
with the families the following day
Kristen and Marta explain the situation
to Daniel including how the kidnappers
are demanding more money this raises
suspicion So Daniel calls Victor right
away accusing the Servants of being
responsible for Marianne's kidnapping
with this information General Oribe and
his team go to Christian's house and
wait for the kidnappers to arrive as
soon as they do the police apprehend
them however Marta who is completely
innocent is taken into custody as well
subsequently the police raid the
military base and Marianne is rescued
and taken away in a police van once she
is gone both the captors and the
captives are executed one after another
the police pour gasoline on the dead
bodies and a fire is ignited making sure
their traces are never found the rescue
which was the only hope for a number of
families turned out to be a massacre
Marianne believes that she is finally
safe and has been rescued but things are
not as they appear General Oribe takes
her to Christian's place where she
exchanges a look with him both of them
are unsure of what will happen soon
after Marianne is shot in front of
Christian and her body is thrown in the
bathroom the police officer hands a gun
to Christian framing him for Marianne's
murder Christine is stunned and Unsure
how to respond before he can utter a
word he is shot and killed as well the
following day Daniel receives bad news
from Victor and general Oribe who claim
Marion was shot to death by the
kidnappers this lie conceals all of the
police's heinous actions in the end Ivan
is seen attending the execution ceremony
with Victor in general Uribe sitting
next to him they are pretending as
though they did nothing wrong Marta is
one of the three people who have been
victimized by the upper High cruelty
soon there executed in front of everyone
this event marks the establishment of a
new order under military control and
those without privileges are left with
no choice but to submit to their rule
the color green is scary I'll never look
at Shrek the same way again subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching